hello there guys and welcome to another
video the trailer for spider-man no way
home just released and it's looking
amazing but you know let's just get
straight to the point of this video
because the brazilian trailer for
spider-man no way home forgot to edit
something out of the trailer which
pretty much confirms um the appearances
of novice spider-man there's also other
parts in the trailer which are teasing
towards the other spider-man which i'll
get into later but first let's discuss
the part that they forgot to edit out so
in the normal version of the trailer you
can see tom holland spider-man jumping
towards the lizard electro and sandman
but even with this version of the
trailer you can tell something is a
little off basically you see spiderman
tom holland's one in the middle going
towards which looks like sandman but the
lizard and electro they're kind of just
jumping into the distance and not at tom
holland spiderman they're just looking
into the distance and you know it's like
where are they going what are they
looking at it doesn't really make sense
so what i'm thinking which i'll confirm
in a second is that they actually edited
out darva spider-man in this sequence so
lizard and electro is going towards
another spider-man which is in sync with
tom holland spider-man so in reality
this clip is actually all free
spider-man jumping at the villains here
now let's go to the brazilian version of
the trailer so it looks like the lizard
here has actually been hit but you know
there's nothing hitting him it just
looks like he's been hit by the air that
is because all the spider-man have been
edited out from this clip because you
know why else would you know the lizard
just get hit randomly like it doesn't
make sense in the normal version of
trailer this doesn't happen this is
obviously because it's been re-edited
but i forgot to do it here and you know
it makes sense because if they weren't
going to jump and attacked other
spider-man why wouldn't they be jumping
towards tom holden spider-man it doesn't
make sense that they're just jumping
into the distance now if you're still
not convinced i do have other evidence
you see here the little railings in the
background does this look familiar by
any chance so just to keep you up to
date if you haven't seen the recent
leaks or the old leaks of andrew
garfield um spider-man there was a leak
where he was basically kneeling down on
the floor with his hand on the railing
and the railings look exactly the same
as this one you could say that was a
coincidence there's another leak with
all three spider-man and these railings
were also in the leaked picture now mind
you this was before this trailer came
out so silver was fake there's just no
way they could have known this set of
railings were going to be in in the
trailer so you know i'm fully convinced
that they're in the movie like this is
so many things that just confirming it
with the potential for spider-man being
edited out here the railings at the back
of this scene being the same as the
leaked photos now with that stuff out of
the way there's also other teasers that
tease the appearance of the spider-man
doctor octopus has um tom holland
spider-man detained and he says you're
not peter parker so obviously he's
referring to toby mcgregor's peter
parker from the sam remy films you could
say this is just a little reference and
not teasing the appearance of lava
spider-man but there is a scene at the
end of the trailer where dr strange says
they're coming through and i can't stop
them now i believe this scene is
actually referring to darva spider-man
marvel knows what they're doing you know
they're doing a little tease at the end
teasing towards toby and andrew i mean
wouldn't it make sense if it's just
teasing the villains because they've
already been showcased throughout the
trailer so it wouldn't make sense to
tease them again so i do believe this is
referring to the arrival of another
spider-man you know that's about it for
this video are you guys convinced or are
you still not convinced let me know in
the comment section below and make sure
to subscribe and like the video to show
your support thanks for watching guys